yeah I don't always do videos like this
in fact I rarely do movie news videos at
this point it's like if it's something
to do with Joker I'll do it but there's
a bit of Henry cavill's flash Warhammer
news out there and I was like that's
cool and then I just couldn't stop
thinking about it and I have no real
Outlet I'm like I live alone
all right I need to talk about it and
it's your ear I need for this and that
thank you for clicking on this video I
do appreciate it so before we talk about
the main event I guess we got it we
should probably do setup here so Henry
Cavill was back as Superman it was kind
of teetering like oh is he still
Superman is he not and then he told
everyone hey I'm back as Superman he was
super pumped to do it must have been a
lot of meetings and a lot of
negotiations that went into that in fact
he was even
spoilers for Black Adam if you haven't
seen Black Adam it's only fair that I
warn you
all right you've been born now so he
even came in for the mid-credits scene
in Black Adam and the movie theater went
[ __ ] bananas everyone was cheering I
was there for it everyone's super
excited and after all that I guess James
Gunn takes over and they just pretty
much told him God yeah
you're Superman for years and wasn't
Superman it was Superman for about 12
minutes and now he's not Superman but
this great man nay this super man did he
rest on that did he wallow in his
Sorrows did he sit at a bar flicking
beer nuts at bottles no the fact did he
go back to The Witcher that's another
thing he quit The Witcher he was so
pumped to be Superman he was like I'm
out Witcher
I don't actually know if those two are
linked but I always assumed they were
chalk that up to me theorizing on the
basis that he quit The Witcher when he
came back as Superman so we saw like
those two might have something to do
with each other did he crawl back to The
Witcher no no Henry Cavill was sitting
around with a little Warhammer
Miniatures and he thought what Warhammer
fans have thought for years which is why
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] isn't there a
Warhammer movie
this is age of Sigmar it's not 40K it's
different this is 40k if it's not done
yet I still need to put the green Hue on
the blades fun work but a work in
progress I love this story because you
know he was like I hope someone makes it
one day and at this moment where he lost
Superman he was like
wait I'm a huge fan and I'm in the
industry and why not be the change you
want to see and Henry Cavill was like
I'm gonna make a Warhammer show or movie
or a something a Warhammer Cinematic
Universe that's the goal here if there
is a universe that is deserving of
Cinematic Universe it's Warhammer it's
actually really difficult to think of a
universe among entertainment as big as
the Warhammer Universe it's the sheer
scope and Scale of the Universe he's
taking on with this you can learn it
watch YouTube videos read it read about
it ingest it when you feel like your
head's gonna pop it's like yeah that's
just one Army in fact it's not just one
Army that's one faction of one Army that
you've been learning there are a lot of
others doesn't actually look too big but
here's the gist and then every Army you
take on has its own book it is an
enormous undertaking adapting these
stories in this universe but I'm glad
it's in the hands of a fan Henry Cavill
is a big Warhammer fan he's never hidden
it which is the antithesis of what you
see with a lot of Studios a lot of
Studios out there are like we don't need
to be fans we just need to have enough
moments in the movie or in the series
that'll track well on social media the
memeable moments that can go viral
that's what we need we don't need to be
fans we don't need to know the lore
whatever so Henry Cav level taken on
Warhammer that's a great move in a right
direction it's a great way to start this
off also an incredible case of making
lemonade out of lemons he was probably
crushed to lose Superman and fans were
sad to see him go as Superman then he
was like I'm gonna do Warhammer I also
want to give a little bit of love to my
favorite Warhammer 40K Channel on
YouTube that would be balder Mort's
guide I'll put a link below now is the
time to get into Warhammer if you're
interested in what Henry Cavill might be
doing Voldemort's voice alone is god
tier but his channel is very engaging
reading about the characters the armies
the factions the lore it can it can feel
like a lot I like the fact that people
can put on the YouTube video listen to
it on their drive to work it makes the
lore more accessible I love that so now
the question is where is it going to
start because like I said it's a huge
Universe it can start anywhere from what
I've heard Henry cavill's Army of choice
is the custodian guard in 40K so I
imagine he'll start there start with
what you love and start with what you
know it's quite a mystical Bond the love
relationship between gamer
and their Warhammer Army anyhow I
thought this news was interesting if not
incredible we're all rooting for Henry
Cavill all right so Henry Cavill no
longer Superman but he's bringing us a
Warhammer 40K Cinematic Universe what do
you think about this news and if you
play Warhammer 40K age of Sigmar what is
your army whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]